good evening members uh resumption of
the meeting of the 15th of December
um
I
have got one or two things to save first
of all councilor Beale is in hospital
again
um so I'm hoping to send
all our best wishes
um
a John cocking who was a counselor for
uh heybridge East from
1987 to 1995 has died recently I won't
ask you to stand
um but I just would like that noted
that he did serve for eight years
um
and I think
to remind members that they have
declared interests but if they find out
another interest or declare during the
meeting
to to do so I therefore move on now to a
gender item 17.
um
urgent business which I had done Council
Fluker
and I'm not really sure where we are
procedure-wise but I I appreciate that
someone would probably uh tell me in a
moment but before I say anything else to
Chairman can I propose chairman that you
and uh the leader of the council send a
card to a councilor bill on behalf of us
all of us I know that ordinarily we
would have signed the card but clearly
that's not happened but I think this is
his third or fourth visit in hospital
I've been to see him recently and uh we
all know Brian and he's doing his best
but he you know he's in fine shape
um Gemini one thing I wanted to to to to
to speak to
um and I'm not sure if it's the right
time or not chairman but it's to do with
the length of meetings chairman in
particular procedural 161.
um clearly what happened last last time
we held this meeting it certainly didn't
look good on the tape with members
standing up and walking out of the
chamber can I ask chairman that um if
perhaps this meeting does last until 10
30.
um the the decision whether or not to
adjourn or close the meeting sits with
the members because last time you had
members walking out of the chamber
before a decision made and and it it
really doesn't look good and chairman I
do now want to uh refer you to
procedural 1.3 M now as far as I'm aware
chairman this this meeting was closed
although the
um this meeting was closed although even
though listening to the tape you
actually adjourned it but after you
closed it there was a suggestion I
picked upon you you closed the meeting
and then afterwards the Mansion officer
sort of said that you'd adjourned it and
then you had to agree that it was closed
and it was closed so my understanding
was at that time then the business
couldn't be followed through to this
couldn't be followed through to this
meeting
um but the monetary officer has ruled
that it can be
um in some ways I find that
slightly disappointing because I know
that members were trying to bring
forward motions right up until the last
moment so that opportunity is gone and I
just hope chairman that
um with regards to the budget meeting
I'm slightly over the place here but
regards the budget meeting I do hope
that officers bearing in mind that it
will likely run past 10 30 and because
of that we should plan for an additional
date now so that members can make uh
Arrangements in advance to make sure
they're there because otherwise it's
sprung on too quickly Gemini revert and
go now back to 1.3 point
one three M of the procedurals tell me
this is to do with leaders questions and
it concerns me enormously that this
members hadn't really had the
opportunity on a lot of occasions now to
put questions to the leader we have a we
have a election in four months we know
that the constitution says that you
can't have leaders questions at the
budget meeting in February so there's
really only one left and I know that
several members would like to ask
questions of the leader and chairman you
rightly said that couldn't happen
because of the time at the LA at the
last meeting I I think Council accepts
that but Tim this is part of that
meeting
this now becomes part of this meeting
and I suspect without looking around and
having just said my watch service and
conditionally it's already two minutes
slow it's 25 to seven
um and it says that you know we can
extend we can extend the meeting and you
can have leaders questions so even
though you're discounted an ass meeting
chairman I would ask you to consider
allowing leaders questions this evening
I believe it will be quite short and if
you're mindful to allow that in the
spirits of democracy openness and
transparency then I think that should
happen now thank you
um uh thank you councilor Fluker I'm not
sure
um what um the actual point of order is
whether it's questions for the leader
which I uh which I have informed you
um via email but it is not good practice
to go back on an agenda
and you mentioned people walking out I
seem to remember that you was the
instigator of people walking out
greatest to respect I would ask you to
look at the tape because that's clearly
not what I saw the meeting was closed
Tim and what I'm saying is my point of
order is quite straightforward 10 p.m no
leaders questions 7 30 in a continuation
but why are we past that agenda item but
why it is a continuation of a meeting as
you've quite rightly pointed out well
chairman left therefore that agenda item
is gone well chairman like the people of
southminster already texted me they're
saying to me is this democracy or not
what's the leader got to hide thank you
the democracy is in the that my ruling
and I don't believe you actually had the
right
um a point of order number it was it
should have been rule one six that you
referred to
um which is
um I think the termination of the
meeting but that's not about the leaders
questions which is a different I mean
you seem to have about three different
points of order
now I will not go back on the um
uh agenda and I shall move on now to a
gender item 17. counselor Stan thank you
chairman um I've actually um took this
this afternoon to actually look at
leaders questions because I think it is
really important for everybody to have
the the opportunity to speak and ask
questions I take on board that it's in
breach of the Constitution and if you'll
just forgive me and allow me a little
bit of time the leader was elected on
the 18th of January 2022 leaders
questions took place on the 3rd of March
one session the 29th of the 9th no
questions due to the lateness of um the
meeting the 3rd of the 11th 2022 there
was leaders questions 15th of December
there was no questions due to the
lateness so that means for the whole of
the Year Mr chairman we've had two
opportunities to raise questions and I
know you're going to stop me and I
understand why but it's not Democratic
and I'm very surprised I'm actually
agreeing with Mr Food Council of Lucas
I know
gender item 17 business by reason of
special circumstances I had none
I now go on to a gender item 18
which is and I propose the exclusion of
the public and press to resolve that
under section 100 A4 of the Local
Government Act 1972 the public be
excluded from the meeting for for the
following items of business on the
grounds they involved the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph three the part one
of schedule 12 a to the ACT and that
satisfies the public interest test is
that second agency
thank you
um it is a motion to counsel and you
have a three minutes to speak oh right
okay so I don't want any more
filibustering tonight we'll have to try
and get the business of the council
completed
I've got no idea so um chairman I mean
quite straightforward I Pace the motion
before this Council and you you agreed
at that time for me to come back and
speak in favor speak to my emotion at
this point that's not disputed the
minutes of the last meeting of this
Council on the 15th of December are
published they're available on the the
websites
um chairman you the your proposal is
that
um that we move this session into
private and confidential chairman I'm
particularly interested in page 123 and
the proposals on that page
um maybe the monitoring office yeah can
I say yes if you're against uh this
motion yeah what you do is you vote
against it well chairman I'm surely I
can speak to it and explain to members
why I think it's right I've given you
that right yes yeah well okay thanks so
that's what I'm going to do but what I'm
going to say I was trying to save your
time because you're Keen not for anybody
to feel about us and I thought well if
the monitoring officer was on the it
could Sun but chairman I mean there's
lots of different issues with this
because even in article one of the
Constitution commits commits the council
to efficiency transparency openness and
accountability in its decision making
chairman I would say that on page 123
which you've just proposed should be
held in private session there are one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten items which are unrelated
chairman for which there is no reason
they should be in private session the
public need go back to the article one
that we need to be open and transparent
when we when we debate those figures I
mean that's what we need to do chairman
and I would propose that with the
exception of uh the first item on page
one two three all other items in the
best interests of the public and
transparency and openness are held in
public session as to do otherwise I
believe would be come true to the local
government thank you
well thanks
um that's an amendment
which is uh which is allowable
I think it is
um that's an amendment
um uh I'll put that to the vote uh uh
straight away
um
but I don't know whether Mr quelch wants
to say anything about the um paragraph
through the Local Government Act yeah my
paragraph three sorry sorry Jim
paragraph three is
um a paragraph that deals with the
business and financial affairs of any
individual including the council itself
but there's two tests isn't there's two
tests the first one is
is this within paragraph three
in other words is it to do with the
business and or financial affairs of the
council and then if it is
um is it in the public interest I think
that's where probably councilor fluka is
going is it in the public interest
um for that to be p and C or does the
need for the public to witness and hear
what said outweigh
so there's two tests number one is it in
paragraph three number two you've got to
apply the public interest test now just
a practicality here from personal
experience
um
uh chairman and that is that you've got
a whole number of issues that are to be
savings as I understand it in this
particular recommendation from strategy
and resources
and yes you could say some of those can
be debated in public
and some can be debated in private you
could do that
um
the trouble is that if you as members
want to want to debate the relative
merits of each saving proposal because
you might not want to go for all of them
and see which ones are more important
than others you may then be straying
into those matters that you said are
public and those matters which are
private if you see what I mean
let me explain it again that you have a
document that has a whole load of
savings proposals that have been
recommended by strategy and resources
as a membership you will be debating not
only individual items the individual
items but you may be assessing the
merits of one against another
particularly if you don't want to accept
all the settings we've been told to say
um I think I think you've made the
position clear uh Mr gross can't we talk
about closer toilets in public so I'll
I'll now put that Amendment uh to the
vote those in favor of the amendment
please show
one two three four gather a call to vote
please chairman thank you bear in mind
what's on that list because it will
become public
this is election year is that second
dude yes that's seconded uh right Tara
um
who will say agree and those who accept
Mr crochet's advice would say
um
against uh uh Taro you're ready to call
a roll how can you close times
foreign
abstain
against
China
against
thank you councilor Zurich
sorry could you repeat that please a
three or four whichever thank you very
much thank you
thank you Kent
against
the speaker four
thank you Council head against
the helm or
that's the keys
against
Council
or please
against
the Morgan against
the morally against
cancer
[Music]
against
cancer full
y not him
the cats are sorry against
okay okay
um thank you that Amendment falls down
in substantive motion is as I um uh
proposed uh those in favor please show
foreign
thank you members
um we are now into private session Tara
at me disconnected from the public